hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on Borderlands 3 again
and you read the title correctly I know
what you're probably thinking just let
me explain throughout the video and
we'll get you sorted out but yes this is
a DLC one XP farm and this can earn you
close towards two maybe even three
million XP per hour depending on which
difficulty you are and how fast you can
complete some of these boss fights as
always spoiler warning ahead just in
case but I think you already knew that
coming into this video but without
further ado let's begin so most of the
gameplay are going to be seeing is on
mayhem three in the calculations that I
will be doing are also going to be on
mayhem three so you can increase that
for mayhem four if you do if you're very
confident with that mode me at the
moment I still play on mayhem four but
I'm not as confident as I am with mayhem
three so that's why I'm doing it with
that the boss that I've been farming and
I think this would come as no surprise
is scrap trap Prime and the scrap trap
nest you could find this in trash Lantis
aka the compactor area he's in the very
top left of the map you'll see on screen
here you pop into the boss fight you
fight these mini scrap traps and I think
there's like 40 or so until the official
health bar is fully down and then a
little bit more come in as the bigger
scrap trap Prime is there and then you
of course have to clear out him and you
can get some legendary to get some XP
now if you're looking to get some really
good legendaries I mean you kind of get
the some of the DLC legendaries from
this boss but if you're really just
looking to get any type of legendary you
want to get like six or seven in a fight
this really isn't the boss to do so like
I said in the title it is strictly in XP
farm obviously if you want to get a
bajillion legendaries every time you
fight him you can of course fight grave
ward all those different people like
that well for the calculations that I
tried to come up with here I'm a hem 3 I
noticed that the small little clap traps
during the nest and also when they come
out during the prime boss fight are
about 1300 XP per kill and if you've
played the boss fight you understand
that there's a load of them and roughly
it takes about 40,000 at 42,000 XP or so
to diminish the entire health bar so
roughly about 40 of them which is very
interesting so that's roughly how much
it takes to get the first part done and
then scrap trap prime will also drop
about 19,000 XP when he is killed so if
he had 42,000 and 19,000 you get 60 1000
XP per boss fight now I managed to
complete this boss fight
about a minute and a half there's a lot
more experienced players than me out
there so you guys could probably beat
this in under a minute some people might
take a little bit longer than me so
adjust appropriately and roughly doing
some math using proportions and [ __ ]
stuff I'd never thought I'd be able to
use in real life I came out to about 2.4
to 2.5 million there's a little bit of
an inflation though because of the
amount of bots in the little robot guys
that you kill because that of course
adds up but roughly it's about two point
four to two point five million XP per
hour I do want to point out that this
was of course on mayhem three if you are
really good at mayhem four have a really
solid build and can wipe this boss in
about a minute or two as well then
you're gonna be looking at options of
like three to four million XP per hour
as well so definitely keep that in mind
yeah that's pretty much it guys I don't
want to waste any more of your time so
you guys can get to grinding of course
XP isn't the most insane things you're
gonna be needing in the game will - at
50 but those Guardian ranks can be
really useful or if you're just trying
to rank up in general that's also
helpful - yeah let me know what you guys
think about the stuff in the comments
below if you have a faster farm
definitely let me know in the comments
as well be sure to check that out thank
you so much B I'd like to be if you're
doing July subscribe for new and take
care peace out
you